The greatest threat to loss of life during a hurricane doesn't come from the wind,...
...it comes from the water that the wind pushes ashore.
This is something that we call storm surge.
You can think of it this way, you're standing on the beach on a bright, summer, sunny afternoon...
...and you watch the tides go out and you watch the tides come in.
Everyone knows that tides are caused by the gravitational pull of the sun and the moon,....
...but add to the mix a powerful storm or hurricane.
When a hurricane moves onshore, its strong winds push water toward the coast...
...piling up water near shore and the water has nowhere to go but up and inland,...
...and it's that water on top of the normal tide that we call the storm surge.
A storm surge can reach as high as 20 feet and extend miles inland,...
...causing devastation, devastating flooding and life-threatening storm surge up and down the coast.
Now that's your Hurricane IQ.